Prince Harry really wants his privacy
he's searched everywhere for privacy
he's gone and turned over every Rock
looking for it he's trekked through the
forests and over mountains in pursuit of
his privacy he's looked for privacy and
interviews with Oprah and in podcasts
and documentaries and his just released
Netflix series and now he's looking for
privacy by publishing an
autobiographical book which will be
released this week and which he promoted
in a 60 Minutes interview and in an
interview on ITV in Britain and in a
Good Morning America interview and then
in an appearance on The Late Show later
this week he's gone in front of every
camera in the world and stepped on every
stage and milked every moment under
every Spotlight he could find all
because he and his wife just want
privacy his upcoming book A tell-all
Memoir much like the type often written
by those who desire privacy more than
anything apparently goes into great
detail but all of his squabbles and
beefs and feuds with his family Harry
has become the world's foremost leader
in the field of over sharing and this
book is exactly what you'd expect from
someone with those kinds of credentials
he not only airs his family's dirty
laundry publicizing and cashing in on
all of his Petty resentments and
familial disputes he also provides
intimate details that even the most
Ardent Harry and Megan fans if such
people could possibly exist would not
have ever solicited for example
he reveals that um this is what he says
in his books his book that he once
suffered frostbite on his genitals
Harry will not even allow his privates
to remain private and yet he just wants
privacy the title of the book spare is a
reference to Harry's feelings of being
the spare the outcast in his family
poor Harry poor poor put upon oppressed
multi-millionaire world famous Harry he
is in so much pain he says and his wife
is also in pain pain and suffering is a
phrase that has come up in multiple
interviews about his book and before his
book talked a lot about it his pain and
suffering his wife's pain and suffering
complains about it and accuses his
family of being complicit quote unquote
in that pain and suffering the general
response to this public Vendetta that
Harry has against his own family has
been to parse through his words trying
to discern what is true what isn't what
needs more context Etc
now personally I have no idea if Harry
is telling the truth or not and I don't
care every family has turmoil and drama
every member of every family has been
both wrong and right both bully and
bullied
families are complicated
and if you're hearing one person's
version of a dispute you could be quite
certain that the other people concerned
those being painted as villains would
have a very different take on things if
you asked them and if they were willing
to answer
this is why family issues should be kept
within the family
you don't have to like every member of
your extended family but there's never a
time when it's necessary or good or
Justified to turn your family drama into
a public spectacle
and this by the way is a lesson that
many people in our society ought to take
to heart now most of us aren't in a
position where we can complain about our
families in a 60 Minutes interview many
people probably would like to do that
but there's just no interest
um yet it is quite common to see people
on a smaller scale
and yet the largest scale available to
them airing their dirty laundry and
family disputes in public to people
around them on social media especially
they provide one side of a complicated
story to an audience that is not
involved that has no business being
involved and that can't do anything with
the information you're giving them or do
anything about the problem to help
resolve it anyway
which is why you know if you have an
issue with your family you should
confront your family and your close
friends in person
tell them how you feel
might even get angry
you might yell I mean these things
happen in families that's normal but in
public
there should be a united front
so you for instance might think that
your brother is an idiot
you might tell him so to his face
but if someone outside your family calls
him an idiot you should take offense at
that and respond accordingly he's an
idiot but he's your idiot because you're
family
this is one of the many things that
Harry gets wrong but it's not just his
family that he feels victimized by he
says it's also the Press
the couple have been on a never-ending
press tour for the past like two years
now doing everything in their power to
attract attention from the press and yet
they are oppressed by the same press
that they can't stop talking to
during his 60 Minutes interview he
explains that the media is bigoted
bigoted against Megan and it's not only
actually the media that's bigoted but uh
listen to this
is what Megan had to go through was was
similar in some part to what Kate and
what committee went through very
different circumstances but then you add
in the race element which was what the
Press British press jumped on straight
away I went into this incredibly naive I
had no idea the British press was so
bigoted hell I was probably bigoted
you're the relationship with with Megan
you'd think you were bigoted before the
relationship with Megan I don't know
put it this way I didn't see
what I now see
you don't know if you're a bigoted how
could you not know if you were bigoted
or not make the New Year all about the
new you with Gen you sell skin care for
a limited time save over 75 off
genucel's most popular package to take
care of all your skin care needs watch
those Fine Lines forehead wrinkles
sagging jawline dark marks skin redness
and even under eye bags disappear my
talent manager Tessa uh we used to call
her assistant in these things so now
it's okay it's been a promotion uses
genucel under eye treatment to help get
rid of the bags under her eyes and she
says it works like a charm I ask her
about it every day and she tells me
still working that's the conversation we
have in real life genu cell skin care
can help you turn back the clock and
look 5 10 even 15 years younger it's
made for both women and men say for all
skin types and works for all ages
genucel promises immediate effects and
results that will make you smile or get
100 of your money back right now get gen
yourself customer favorite a deep
firming vitamin C serum it's absolutely
free in every most popular package you
could hydrate your skin while restoring
your natural natural vibrant glow visit
genucel.com Walsh and use code wall
should check out every order is
automatically upgraded to free shipping
that's genucel.com Welsh genucel.com
Welsh
now this is mostly empty virtue
signaling of course here Harry is uh
doing the work and doing the work means
baselessly accusing everyone including
yourself of bigotry
but that's not to say that he that he's
being entirely insincere it's clear that
the man has been genuinely brainwashed
into the religion of wokism and in that
religion bigotry is the original sin but
not shared by all people shared only by
members of the white race
this is uh it's the the original sin of
white people and uh people who are not
white have no sins at all
it is a hazy undefinable sort of evil
shared by every member of the white race
Harry doesn't remember any specific
occasion of being bigoted he never
harbored any racial animosity towards
non-white people and yet
even though this by definition means
that he was not racially bigoted he
still cannot declare himself to have not
been bigoted
Because the actual belief of the woke
white person is that he himself cannot
speak to his own racism or lack thereof
he is not an expert in his own thoughts
and feelings
it's up to a member of the racial victim
class to determine whether he is racist
or not from one moment to the next
he cannot speak to his own motivations
and intentions but they can
and now that Harry is married to a a
member of that racial victim class uh
she can she can attest to his
non-bigatree now
but before her she was not there to
absolve him and that's the way he sees
it
and finally speaking of Megan um
this is Maybe
the most important or at least most
useful point for most of them
let her be a warning to men everywhere
because although Harry is no victim no
martyr much as he wishes to be he is
still a pitiful and pathetic figure a
broken shell of a man
he's still rich and famous but he's no
longer respected
and that's the worst thing the worst
thing a man can lose is respect
a man can live and be happy without much
money without many things but the loss
of respect is what truly devastates and
in many cases can prove fatal
and Harry has become a man who is no
longer respectable in large part because
he married a woman who does not respect
him this is the influence that a woman
can have over a man her feelings about
him often become a sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy
I think it was G.K Chesterton who noted
that the uh noted the the positive end
of this kind of relationship explaining
how the lesson of Beauty and the Beast
is that a man must be loved in order to
become lovable Beauty lifts up the Beast
her love helping him to become the man
he was meant to be but a bad woman can
have the opposite effect turning a
prince back into a beast in this case a
whiny petulant baby beast but a beast
all the same
my wife has helped me to become a better
man because she loves and respects me
and when you love and respect something
you want it to be the best version of
itself but then there are the Meghan
markles of the world who will break a
man instead of building him up bringing
out his worst aspects while smothering
all that was good in him this is the the
nightmare scenario that has chased many
men away from Marriage as we've
discussed over the last few days but the
good news is that it's pretty easy to
spot the Meghan markles
so easy that most of us had the actual
Meghan Markle figured out after
listening to her speak for like 45
seconds
either Harry didn't see it because he
allowed himself to be blinded by her
good looks or wouldn't be the first man
to fall into that trap or he did see it
and decided to move forward anyway
perhaps partially motivated by his
simmering resentment for his family
whatever the case
there's a very basic checklist that a
man should refer to when dating a woman
and the woman should have a similar
mental checklist in mind when dating the
man the first and biggest question
and the one that a Discerning man should
be able to answer rather easily is does
she respect you
you should be able to figure that out
pretty quickly
what what an important skill for a man
to learn is this is to is to be able to
identify when he's not being respected
also does she cheer you on does she root
for your success and happiness or is she
more focused on her own
does she desire for you to have a close
relationship with your family
or does she want to isolate you from
everyone you know and love
does she talk about herself all the time
or does she spend more time asking
questions about you is she sincere is
she kind
or do does she only appear to be kind in
public but then you see her rolling her
eyes behind the scenes does she have
empathy
these are the questions to ask yourself
when Discerning marriage now it's
possible that a very gifted phony may be
able to deceive you on many or even all
of these points but most phonies are not
that gifted Meghan Markle certainly
isn't
which is why I was able to answer all of
these questions about her about five
minutes after discovering that she
existed
okay I didn't even know she existed five
minutes later I knew everything I needed
to know about her
Harry should have been able to answer
them but if he did
he ignored the answers
and now he is paying the price that'll
do it for this portion of the shows and
move over to the members block you can
become a member and watch the members
block by using Code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
hope see over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]